et si l'homme et la machine travailler
main dans la main
c'est en tout cas le souhait de
l'entreprise en caux radio mix qui va
chapeauter le projet dragon ce programme
aura recours à l'intelligence
artificielle et au dip learning pour
aider les médecins à mieux diagnostiquer
la maladie et à choisir les traitements
en fonction
on va utiliser d'abord les images du
patient décédé scannage c'était et on va
augmenter ses données avec des données
biologiques ou des données de patients
pour créer des modèles qui sont les faux
à trouver des passions avec du coït à et
à essayer de prédire quel est le trajet
pour ce patient continue à le coup vite
cette pme a déjà mis au point un
programme en collaboration avec le chu
de liège pour déterminer si les patients
sont atteints du coc vide 19 grâce à une
radio en 3d les poumons d'un patient
l'outil est capable avec une précision
annoncé de 97% de déterminer si une
personne est atteinte du coroner virus
la procédure prend moins de dix minutes
alors qu'un test pcr pour trois jours
donc on les a contactés pour mettre au
point vraiment un outil de prise en
charge qui permettait de dire bah tiens
ce patient est là aux probabilités
d'avoir un kobe de 19 ou pas trop et
donc on a proposé avec encore à de mix
de base et une analyse sur la présence
d'une infection par kobe de prouver par
les techniques connues comme la pcr qui
va permettre de trouver le diagnostic et
on a comparé ces patients-là à plus de
mille patients qui ont d'autres maladies
toutes confondues sans faire la part des
choses entre les antécédents du patient
l'infection concomitants par une
bactérie la présence d'un cancer du
poumon
afin de pouvoir déterminer si oui ou non
on pouvait créer un outil performant
très spécifiques et donc très très
capable de pouvoir diagnostiquer
l'infection par corinne 6,9 la
pertinence du projet dragon a retenu
l'attention de l'union européenne dans
le cadre du mécanisme innovative
medicines initiative qui soutient la
recherche pharmaceutique
une subvention de 11,4 millions d'euros
vient d'être octroyée au projet
vingt partenaires de belgique de chine
d'italie des pays bas de suisse et du
royaume uni seront réunis dans le cadre
du programme dragon parmi eux une start
up belge med ces deux cette dernière
développe des applications pour aider
l'accompagnement des patients et des
médecins en proposant de l'information
individualisé par le biais de modèles
prédictifs donc en fonction de ses
besoins vont effectivement on touche la
population de façon générale il va
recevoir de l'information déjà sur les
directives à jour à jour sur qu'est-ce
qui recommandait on va lui proposer des
actions de prévention il va pouvoir
poser des questions directement à
l'application et avoir les réponses
qu'ils recherchent et on peut également
l'orienter vers les bonnes personnes
s'il ya des questions auxquelles nous on
veut pas répondre et ensuite
effectivement il ya tout un tas de
questionnaires qu'on va pouvoir utiliser
à des moments où le patient va avoir de
l'information sur son état de santé sur
ce qu'ils devraient faire qui vont
permettre donc de huy de lui donner les
bonnes directives en plus d'aider les
médecins pour le traitement des patients
atteints du coït 19 le projet dragon
permettra aussi aux patients d'utiliser
eux mêmes certains outils visant
notamment à faciliter le recours à la
médecine préventive